in this video we'll be attempting to
explain the entire demon slayer story in
under 10 minutes no time to waste let's
get started it all started about a
thousand years ago when a young frail
boy was born who was so sick he could
die any moment the boy was stillborn
with no pulse or breathing but at the
time of his cremation he started crying
for the very first time since his birth
the child suffered from an unknown
illness that greatly weakened him and
lowered his life expectancy to only 20
years the doctor treating him gave him a
special medicine having the blue lily
flower in it which saved the boy
providing him great strength but turned
him into something inhuman a demon that
craved human flesh having no weaknesses
but the sunlight although the boy was
saved he cursed the bloodline of his own
family causing all the future
generations to suffer from the same
illness as him however the family was
instructed by a priest to slay the first
demon to save their family from dying
out the sickly boy became the demon king
muzon kibutsuji and the uyashuki family
laid the foundation for the demon slayer
core the demon's lair core tried to hunt
down muzon over the years while he was
busy injecting his blood into other
people and building an army of demons to
protect himself muzan was on the hunt
for the red lily flower a flower that
promised to eradicate his one remaining
weakness making him the most powerful
being on earth after some time muzan
comes in contact with a marked demon
slayer michikatsu sugi kuni who uses the
moon breathing style michikatsu wished
to become more stronger than his brother
this game was on the perfect opportunity
to invite him to the dark side offering
him a long life and great strength
michikatsu then became the upper moon
one known as the kokushiba later muzon
had his very first near-death experience
thanks to kushiba's twin brother yurichi
sukukuni yurishi was an incredible demon
slayer that possessed godly attributes
such that he almost killed the demon
king too although muzon survived he was
scarred for life judy reaches terrifying
strength before his death yurichi on
requests of his dear friend sumiyoshi
kamado's wife performed his hinokami
kagura and also gave the couple his son
of food at earrings the kamado couple
was enchanted by his dance and
immediately memorized it too and that's
how the great swordman yurichi is
connected to the kamado family some
centuries later we get to see the kamado
family living on top of a hill the
eldest of the siblings being tanjuro and
nezuko who are also our protagonists
donjiro being the oldest takes care of
most of the work that required strength
like selling coals in the village one
day when he was coming back muzon
slaughtered his entire family and
unintentionally turned nezuko into a
demon tanjimo was horrified but soon
realized that there might be hope for
nezuko and as he was about to take her
to the hospital he was attacked by
neziko judo were thirst for human flesh
and at the same time the water hashira
kyutomayoku came gea was adamant about
slaying nezuko but due to tantra's
persistence and nezuko's control over
her urges due to her love and care for
him to stop guru from killing both kyou
then takes the kamado siblings to his
master and the previous water hashira
hirokudaki tantro trains under him to
get stronger enough to take revenge for
his family and to return nezuko to
normal tanzero trains under him for a
year whereas nezuko falls into a deep
slumber to conserve her energy tantro
then takes part in the demon slayer exam
to join the demon selera core tantrum
manages to stay alive in the demon
forest for seven nights straight and
passes the exam once the exam is over
tundra gets his niece and sword made and
embarks on his first mission carrying
nezuko inside a special box on his first
mission tantra faces a demon that uses
blood demon art and has been kidnapping
girls from a village tantro's next
destination is tokyo where he first
encounters muzan tanju notices the
familiar scent and follows the demon
king but is easily fooled by him into
thinking that he's a human tantra gets
distracted by a demon while muzan makes
his escape their tantra becomes
acquainted with tamiyo and yushiro who
claim to have been making an antidote
that converts demons back into humans
muzan is reminded of his great fear when
he sees tanjuro's earrings and recalls
his past with yurichi when muzon almost
got killed tanjuak is ambushed by the
demons but successfully defeats them
with the help of tamiyo yushiro and
nezuko he then departs again with nezuko
for another mission and gets acquainted
with the eccentric zhenitsu agatsumi
tanjiro and zenitsu are then directed to
a mansion on the hill by a crow for a
mission tundra gets acquainted with the
warhead of the nosuke during his mission
in the mansion recites a powerful demon
at the rank of lower moon six trying to
save the two children inside the mansion
tangerine and zenitsu confront the demon
and enosuke tags along zenitsu and
enosuke demonstrate their powers and
helped andrew in defeating the lower
moon demon the trio then stay for a
short while in the house with the
wisteria family sigil and then embark on
a new journey to mount natagumo on the
instruction of the kasugai crow
meanwhile giu and shinobu are also
instructed by kagaya to investigate
mount natagumo the trio comes in contact
with the family of a powerful lower moon
rank 11 demon rui zenitsu using his
breath of lightning fights against
ruby's brother while anaska handles his
father using his beast breathing
technique and spatial awareness rui
tries to get his hands on nezuko to make
her join his family and use her against
anjaro but at that moment tangible
recalls the hindu kami kagura dance
shifting his water breathing style to
sun breathing style and slashes rui's
neck however he is unable to land the
killing blow and is saved by giu who
informs him to leave with nezuko due to
his orders for eliminating all the
demons on mount natagumo the siblings
get captured and are presented in front
of the hashiros but the head of the
demon's layer core kikaya ubuyashiki the
hasheras wanted to execute nezuko but
due to the insistence of guil and the
former wada shashira the siblings were
set free on one condition that nezuko be
killed immediately when she eats a human
what's more tangible was also left alive
due to him being the only one in the
demon slayer core to have seen the demon
king in person tangier rosenito and
enosuke then trained with genya and
kaneo to strengthen their breathing
technique meanwhile musan kills the
lower moon demons leaving only the rank
7 behind and offers him his blood to
kill tanjiro the trio was ordered to go
to the infinite train where they come
across the flame ashira and goku tanjura
tries to inquire about the hirokami
kagura to which one goku shares that his
father might know something about it on
the train the lower moon rank 7 demon is
present and uses a spell to put all the
passengers in a never-ending sleep
tantrum dreams about his family being
alive making him feel extremely happy
however he soon realizes that he has to
kill himself to break from the spell
niziku awakens sanjiro who then goes to
fight against anmu while run goku also
awakens and keeps the passengers safe
enosuke joins tangero in fighting
against zenmu who keeps using the sleep
spell on tanjiro confusing him between
dreams and reality as soon as enmu's
killed akuza the upper moon rank 3
arrives sanjiro and enosuke are unable
to do anything against akaza and
submarine goku tries to fight against
him ringoku puts up a great fight to
which he's invited by akuza to become a
demon rengoku says that he is a human
and will be a human till his death akuza
kills from goku and manages to escape at
dawn akkason returns to muzan but the
news of kyogre and goku's death but
muzan is unimpressed by it a distraught
tanjiro follows kyoto's crew to his home
and releases the shira's message to his
younger brother cinderella and goku
kimojo's father berates his late son
badly and destroys his records so that
tanjura won't get any information about
the hindu kami kagura later his father
starts crying upon hearing about kyoto's
death tanjore with zendizu and anosake
continue their journey with the sound to
jira tenganuzui who was in search for
his missing wives the two disguised
themselves as girls to continue their
investigation in the red light district
the demon slayers find out that daki of
the upper moon rank 6 is behind the
kidnapping and confront her in a battle
the fight with daki is very important as
it evolved the kamado siblings it made
them much stronger tantra got a better
grip on the hinoka kagura and nezuko
awakened her full demon form to fight
against daki however after defeating
daki her older brother gyotaro the upper
moon rank six awakened as both siblings
shared one body fortunately the demon
was killed with the help of the sound to
shira and tanjuro tajiro camano then
travels to swordsmith village to get his
niece and blade replaced tanjara finds
out about the urichi type zero training
doll through the mists of shira and
trains with it to the point that it cuts
off the doll's head and finds a 300 year
old sword inside it hotaru the
swordsmith takes a look at the sword and
offers to repair it for tanjuro's use
meanwhile muzan sends the upper moon
rank 4 and 5 to destroy the sword smith
village thankfully the demons were slain
with the help of nezuko tajiro genya
mitsuri and muitero tokito nezuko
attained immunity from the sun which
piqued roussan's interest and he shifted
his complete attention to devouring
nezuko the demon slayers realized that
they had to become much more powerful to
defeat muzan so they started the hashira
training period while the shiras were
training muzan paid a visit to kagaya
and threatened him kagaya in an attempt
to completely eradicate muzan blew up
his house along with his wife and two
daughters tomio appears and stabs was on
with a drug that turns demons into
humans to weaken him unfortunately the
demon his daughter is later killed by
muzan in the meantime all the heshiras
along with the young demon slayers
arrive in corner muzon the new upper
rank 4 nakime helps himself in
retreating to the infinity castle and
drags all the hasheras and demon slayers
with her the shires get completely
surrounded by demons there whereas
shinobu opens the door to a room where
the upper moon rank 2 is feasting on
several women shinobu allows them to eat
her just so she can poison him enough to
weaken him this allows kaneo and onosuke
to successfully kill doma guillo and
tajiro face off against akusa who proves
to be a troublesome opponent but the duo
manages to somehow defeat him while
zetty too fights against the senior
kigaku who became the new upper moon
rank six the love of shira and surfer
tajira confront nakime who proves to be
quite hard to take down giu tanjiro and
yushiro provide their assistance in
beheading the upper moon rank four the
mystishira was thrown into a different
location and comes across kokushiba the
fight with gokushima doesn't last long
as the mystician was easily defeated
genya tries to offer his help and gets
both of his arms slashed instead
fortunately gyome the strongest ashira
arrives who puts up a good fight against
gokushiba guillemi manages to defeat the
upper rank 1 with the help of the missed
ashira musan suddenly bursts out of his
cocoon of flesh with a new appearance
and power to fight against the demon
slayers using his powers the demon lord
poisons the mysticshira the serpent to
shira tanjiro and the other demons
layers pretty badly both the hasheras
die in each other's arms but tanjiro is
saved by yushiro's medicine while being
unconscious from zuzan's attack tanjo
dreams about the ancient memories of
yurichi and learns the 13th form of the
hirokami kagura tanjiro upon waking up
uses his new learn technique against
muzan which proves to be quite useful
but still not enough combined with gyome
giu xiaomi zenitsu and ninosuke's powers
chandra manages to successfully defeat
muzan however muzon transferred all of
his remaining blood and cells to tanjuro
turning him into a demon saying that if
tanjoro survives he will be much
stronger than muzan and then he should
carry out the mission to annihilate the
demon slayer core tanjiro awakens from
his demon king form and he starts
attacking the demon slayers around him
kaneo swiftly manages to inject tanjiri
with the medicine that shinobu and
tamoya created for turning demons into
humans chandra stays resilient and muzan
is finally defeated for good afterward
the demon's lair core is disbanded for
good nezuko also turns into a human and
lives happily alongside tanjiro zetnizu
and anasuke in the old kamado house